[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr
greg sadler and today we're talking
about
philosophy as a way of life and
you may say well isn't that a no-brainer
obviously it's a way of life
at least for some philosophers but you
know you might be surprised if you look
at how it's done
a lot these days and we really have a
special treat and something new that
we're trying here
on the show we have a friend and
colleague john
sellers who's over in england uh in
great britain
and obviously you know he's not going to
be live
on the show because we record this at a
time that would be kind of late at night
for
for them over there so i recorded an
interview
with john sellers last week about
philosophy as a way of life
and we're going to be playing parts of
it here and doing you know what
um you know so many other radio shows do
right splicing in interviews
but for dan and i this is uh something a
little bit new so hopefully it's going
to go without any
real hiccups and
you might say john sellers who's this
guy well he wrote a really nice
article about three years back asking
the question and answering the question
what is philosophy as a way of life he's
one of the
big contributors to that movement and
the presence so
and he's also got a you know beautiful
english accent that some of you might
get into
as well so i think you'll you'll enjoy
hearing
what he has to say and and i know dan
you you read the article
uh you had some some thoughts about it
as well
yeah i just wanted to like extend that
uh sellers is
also a um
reader and philosophy at the royal
holloway university of london a visiting
research fellow at the king's college
london
and a member of the wolfson college in
oxford
you know he's also uh one of the
original founders of the modern stoicism
project too
yes he's uh many accolades to his name
and he's also got a pretty decent why
i'd say it's actually quite great
um book uh called justicism um which was
actually one of my first
um real academic dives into stoicism
besides you know your
the fluffy uh things that you see on the
internet
well that's really cool yeah i've i've
read some of his his uh
more heavy hitting books too on on
stoicism i've been impressed by him i
didn't know that you
you had um encountered him earlier in
that that's kind of cool
yeah it's actually i use it as a
textbook course on stoicism that took on
rather early in my um
examination of socialism and and
velocity in a more
broad sense wow well you know i'll have
to tell him that that's really
interesting well he'll probably hear
this on the on the show anyway
hopefully hi john um
and uh otherwise like he he wrote
um a an article on uh philosophy as a
way of life
uh what in 2017 yeah 17
yeah which you can you can get for free
on the internet we'll put a link to that
in the journal parasia which means
freedom of speech or or frank talking
you know
uh telling it how it is right
um and um i don't want to go too much
into it because
he touches on a lot of his main topics
in this interview and so i'd
rather let him speak for himself there
was something that you
you particularly liked about it though
right yeah um early on while he's
kind of talking about what it is
uh as a philosophy as a way of life um
he said that he was very uh influenced
by at least
in part um nietzsche's frederic
friedrich nietras
um schopenhauer as an educator and the
quote i attach
importance to a philosopher only to the
extent
that he is capable of setting an example
the philosopher must supply
this example in his visible life and not
merely in his books that is it must be
presented
in the way the philosophers of greece
taught
through facial expressions demeanor
clothing
food and custom more than through what
they said
let alone what they wrote
why do you find that so particularly
compelling i think it's a
it's a great idea but i'm curious to
know
what drew you to that that passage
it really sets up this this nice
dichotomy between
kind of your academic philosopher and
your philosopher as a practitioner of a
philosophy as a way of life
and how these two terms get muddled and
how the terms have been
at least in common parlance uh shifted
from one to the other from
philosophy as a way of life to more that
academic uh
you know in the you know was it
gilded halls of the ivory tower
yeah and that we could put some diamonds
on the floor maybe too or something
like that i like that i like that word
practitioner um
you know there's something there's
something compelling about that
you know that um a philosopher is a
theorist
but it can't just be theory right right
it is theory
mixed and intermingled with you know
your your day-to-day life you're you're
practicing
kind of i don't know practice what you
preach to
borrow the term um to
try to comport your life with those uh
ideals that you hold to be you know as
we'll talk about later true
yeah so this is a good jumping off point
to start bringing
john sellers explicitly into the show
and i'm gonna
play for you one of the clips that we we
have
what is philosophy as a way of life what
does that term actually
mean a lot of people throw it around but
you're an expert on this what what do
you take it to mean
yeah that is a really good question
and i guess there are a number of
different ways you might understand it
so one way to understand it
would be the idea that philosophy is
some kind of guide
to how to live that philosophy is going
to give you some
advice or practical tips or if it's a
more
um what's the word a more it has a kind
of more moralistic ethics then it's
going to tell you what you ought to do
right so that would be one way to think
about it the
philosophy is going to give you that
practical guidance um
another way to think about it might be
the idea
that philosophy quite literally is a way
of life
so philosophy is something that isn't
merely a matter of words and
arguments and debate and discussion but
it's something that's actually expressed
in your behavior
right so the philosopher um
you know thinking about ancient
philosophy in particular for instance
the philosopher
um is the virtuous individual who acts
virtuously
and so you can see that they've gained
that wisdom and that knowledge
through their behavior and not through
anything they say
so that might be a kind of a slightly
more extreme way of thinking about
philosophy as a way of life it's simply
a matter of actions
um and then i think a third perhaps more
modest way of thinking about it
might be simply that philosophy could be
a way of life in the sense that it's
the overwhelming activity in your life
so it's not necessary that philosophy
guides you
into how to be a good moral agent or
something like that
but the philosophy becomes that
all-encompassing activity
that effectively forms a way of life in
the way in which
um you know music might form um
occupy someone's life and all of their
attention and they live the life of a
musician we might say
that you could imagine saying living the
life of a philosopher
that could apply to a lot of academics
right a lot of academics completely
absorbed in their subject right but not
necessarily thinking that philosophy is
a way of life they might be obsessed
with logical paradoxes or something
so so to follow up on that one way of
talking about philosophy in ancient
times is
it's the art of living and aristotle
talked about some
arts or disciplines being architectonic
and that they would they would rule over
others so you're this third way you're
suggesting
that philosophy would not just be
something that you do
and that gives you guidance but it would
also inform the
other things that you're doing is that
the idea behind it
yeah that's a good question um
i didn't i didn't have that in mind to
be honest but but now that you say that
i think that is actually also a really
good way of thinking about it
uh as something that would would shape
all of the activities that you do and
inform all of the ways in which you
uh might live i think that might fall
into
yeah that's that might be another way in
which we could think about it i mean i
thought it's interesting that you
mentioned aristotle
because i kind of had aristotle in mind
for
the third of those ways that i mentioned
um
so as i've written in a in a paper that
i know you've
you've looked at recently i'm not so
convinced that aristotle thinks that
philosophy
primarily offers us guidance for how to
live
but i do think that aristotle thought
that philosophy
ought to be the activity that people
should engage in and that could fulfill
their life
through a life of contemplation um
so that might that might be another way
to think about what's going on here
so you know actually let me ask you dan
you know i'm a philosophy professor
and it's kind of natural that if i'm
inclined to
make it a way of life that i would do so
but you're somebody who came to it
you know um you had some philosophy
classes but you came to it as
uh somebody who who doesn't have a
vested interest so to speak
right in it from the start what i mean
what drew you into
thinking about philosophy is something
that you wanted to make central in your
own life
i guess i would have to push back on you
because
you know i may not have a a monetary
vested interest
but i do have a vested interest in
uh having a you know a little bit of
equanimity in my life okay yeah a
a reason for why i do things i think
these are are
definitely uh things to be desired if we
remove them from
um the the area that we're only saying
oh it's
you should only care about if it makes
you money i think it's going to be
a very small amount of things
it could be a vested interest as well as
in like one status or something
along those lines right is you know to
if we're going to use the ivory tower my
ivory tower is higher than your ivory
tower or something
like that actually we should talk too
sellers talked about
uh academic philosophy in the interview
how is philosophy as a way of life
something different than what
some of our listeners might have
encountered say in an intro to
philosophy class or a textbook or
watching course videos or something
where it's a traditional academic
setting
that's a good question i think i think
really when people are talking about
philosophy as a way of life
they're thinking of some kind of
intellectual rational reflection
that is going to inform all of the
activities
they do after they step outside of the
classroom
or the seminar room it's not merely the
intellectual pursuit
that you engage in in the classroom and
you could imagine
an academic professor completely
absorbed in
whatever technical problems that they're
doing there's a sense in which they're
living a life of philosophy
but that's not really what we put in
mind when we talk about philosophy of
way of life right
we we want to think that those
intellectual pursuits of theirs actually
inform the decisions that they make
throughout their lives i mean as
academic philosophers we both know
of various horror stories of famous
professors of ethics that have done
unspeakable things in their in their in
their private lives and
and quite rightly well everyone's
obviously deeply disturbed at terrible
things that people have done
but they're all the more disturbed by
the fact that these are people that have
spent their day thinking about
what morally is the right or wrong thing
to do but have completely failed to if
you like learn any valuable lessons from
that
and transport them into how they behave
you know um in the rest of their time
so that's kind of a damning thing about
academics right there
isn't it um so go ahead i found this to
be really interesting
in uh how kind of like he's talking
about this compartmentalization
yeah if you're a magician you go and you
you
you go and you work on your logic and
then you
at the end of the day you drop it and
then you go off and you do
whatever it is that you do and or in the
case of these
moral philosophers that do morally
reprehensible things is
it is a a jaw a job that you kind of
compartmentalize
and then you you drop it and and like
how can you
you drop this thing that is uh
supposedly the odds of how one should
live yeah
central to your life and the stuff he's
referring to is primarily
older male um big name philosophers
uh sexual harassing and
in some cases assaulting um graduate
students
which and then the school not doing
anything about it which is really quite
terrible
um and so the compartmentalization can
take place not just you know like as
here's my academic setting and then
here's my
like everything else setting it can even
happen in the academic
framework where people are doing things
you're like your philosophy would seem
to say
you should be doing other than that and
and you're not
um okay the question is is is there a
philosophy or is it just
something that they you know twiddle
with and yeah
try to make sure that the uh has good
reasoning
yeah something that will stand up
against the scrutiny of their colleagues
but not you could say
the average person on the street saying
what the hell is wrong with you
i'm kind of curious dan so um your
your experience with academic philosophy
um
did you find it you know helpful
or was it only through turning to you
know like studying stoicism or things
like that that you got you got something
that
fit and and wasn't compartmentalized um
i i really enjoyed my my ethics work
and at least
it exposed you to a whole lot of
different
moral philosophies and so it allows you
to go okay like
you know what are there these things
that you can actually start to
dive into um although none of them of my
coursework ever asked me to asked me to
actually
practice any of these things it was all
a very academic pursuit
um i i wouldn't say it was
for not i found it very intellectually
stimulating and it did
lead me to something that was much more
practice
based um but
oh i i take it or leave it i guess in
that regard
well i think that's a pretty normal
experience and i can say something quite
similar about the teaching
in my academic courses as an
undergraduate there was very little in
the philosophy curriculum that would
lead you believe that you'd actually do
something with this stuff
i just happened to do that because i i
wasn't you know i
i was a first generation student i
didn't know that you weren't supposed to
do anything with this stuff
so i thought you were you know you may
as well
now uh settlers had another thing and we
i asked him a little bit of his his
backstory and
um we'll we'll tell a little bit of a
story after oh go ahead
quickly i kind of wish that some of the
um like first year psychology students
are often told to go out and do these
experiments yes
to kind of shake up how you see the
world and how people react to you
i kind of wish that philosophy would
grab a little bit of that
yeah i mean there is a field called
experimental philosophy
but they're much more oriented towards
trying to like set up good experiments
rather than
doing that purely experiential stuff
you know well so i asked sellers about
his
his own getting into this and here's
what he had to say
how did you end up being attracted to
and involved in this way of doing
and interpreting philosophy which i take
is a very important concern for you
yeah that's that that is a good question
and i don't think i've really spoken
much about the kind of
autobiographical side of things
um i suppose when i was
when i was a teenager before going to
study philosophy
i was studying politics and i was very
interested in politics and i was reading
a lot of stuff
like that reading stuff about marxism
and anarchism and those sorts of
traditions
as lots of people do at that age and i
think that
was in part thinking about how to live
one's life
what values to adopt how to behave
what's worth pursuing
what's most important so those were the
sorts of questions that i think were in
the back of my mind
when i first went to study philosophy
and as a school kid
in the subjects that i was best at were
mathematics and physics
and that could have been another path i
could have gone down but it didn't
happen
so that interest in politics led me to
study philosophy
and with a strong background in
mathematics i thought
that logic might be something that i
would excel at
and it would be a natural thing to go
down and it and
initially i thought that could be very
very interesting and then i remember
a certain moment again sort of typical
almost caricature of a
of a first year philosophy student
reading lots of nature
because you know that's what you do if
you're a philosophy student and going to
my logic classes
and just the the tension between these
two very different experiences
and this feeling that nietzsche was kind
of speaking to me
about how i ought to live my life and
the logic lessons weren't
and i think that that was a certain
moment that started to put me on this
path
and of course one thing that i think i
really learned from nietzsche is i
learned ancient philosophy from
nietzsche
in a sense so my undergraduate degree
we would we studied plato in particular
but not that many
other people but it was nietzsche who
introduced me to
seneca and plutarch and epicurus and
diogenes lauritias
and epictetus it was reading nietzsche's
works that first
dropped all of these ancient names and
of course in his essay shopping house
educator
he famously draws a contrast between the
the stale
academic philosophy of of 19th century
germany
and the philosophers of ancient greece
who didn't just talk the talk but also
walked the walk
so that was my kind of path towards
thinking about philosophy's way of life
and then around the time i i finished my
reading finished my degree and was
thinking about what to do next
i knew i wanted to continue in academic
philosophy in some way but i had no idea
what shape that would take
and this was 1995 and it was the year
that pierre hadeau's book
philosophy as a way of life came out and
i just
picked that up by chance in a bookstore
just one of those random moments in life
that happens
and this was a book that connected those
interests
in european philosophy
nietzsche various other existentialists
and the study of ancient philosophy
and he kind of joined all the dots of
things i was already interested in
and gave a kind of a theoretical
framework um there's an irene irony of
course and calling a theoretical
framework but you know what i mean
a kind of a methodological framework for
all of these things that that
had been coalescing in my mind
yeah so i mean i think everybody's got a
backstory right and
and this is kind of cool to actually get
to air sellers which he hasn't talked
about
all that much but um i mean what's yours
stan i mean you
you and i have been talking now pretty
regularly for a couple of years
so i know quite quite a bit of it but
every time that we
that i answer ask you one of these
questions on the show i usually get some
answer that that reveals something i
didn't know
um i guess uh finishing college um
you know mostly you know a major in
computer sciences
at the university of wisconsin and uh i
took
you know at wisconsin that make sure you
have a liberal education so you have
depth and breadth and so you had to take
a number of humanities courses
in order to get your breadth of your
education
and um ended up taking a couple at the
the very
like last year i took a couple that
really started to
bring me into it was um
oh uh one course which was in the
english department but it was
deep into uh philosophy talking about um
how data and identity
and the modern world um
shape us and how and and memory um so it
like starts off with like
you know you're you're at top of the
rasa and it ends with robocop
um and so you have this whole gamut of
different thoughts and you know you've
got to throw in your philip k deck in
there because he's
all about memory and how he's actually
um stabilize the replicant
yeah um and um and it really
brought into this idea of like what's
the question of why
because i my my degree is going to get
me a
how i can i can build things hooray but
why why should i do any of these things
and um that was an
incredibly compelling uh question
especially at the end of my
uh college career it was a lot more
enticing to think about that than
you know right in my programs um and and
then
also because i was under a large amount
of stress from that and a couple of
other things that were going on in my
life the time
um i also fell into um
reading about stoicism at this time and
it gave me a framework
that really was able to help me deal
with that stressful time
and kind of calm my turbulent mind
a little follow-up how did you wind up
getting steered towards stoicism because
that i mean that seems like one of the
big heavy hitters for philosophy as a
way of life today
um i it was
i was doing an all-nighter working on a
program for bioinformatics i believe i
was working on a program that was
sequencing
um oh i think influenza
uh using uh bits of of sequence that
were like
three to uh six characters of
dna long or i guess it's rna because
it's a
virus virus yeah um and
uh at 3am i just needed a moment to like
get away and push myself and it was
actually
um a i was just like i need to like
not think about this and sort of surfing
um and i
stumbled upon a article that was on
tim ferriss's website uh he had someone
on and i can't remember
exactly who but they just had like maybe
a three-page write-up of
the basic ideas of stoicism i'm like
wow and it was just like this
inspiration moment and that's that's
where i was like oh well i really need
to read more about this and that's
how it started that's pretty cool
one more follow-up too i know we're
going a little bit over the time that we
wanted with this but
did you find yourself like was it sort
of like a
snowball process where you you read a
bit and then you're like oh and that
refers to this and refers to this and
then you know the snowball keeps getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and
moving faster and faster i mean there's
enough stuff out there on stoicism that
you could easily go down a bunch of
rabbit holes like that right right so
like
i i branched out and one of the really
early things that i actually
read before i actually read the ancients
was this book philosophy as a way of
life by appearing oh
we're just talking about it yeah yeah um
you know i i
read a little bit of the the ancients
but it wasn't a whole lot
um uh and but that book is incredibly
enlightening and it
because it does have this breath because
he is uh such a great scholar of
velocity that he can kind of like
pick it's like okay these things work
well well when we think about them in
this way
and how um all these different uh
practitioners of philosophy as a way of
life um and the the things that they did
actually to do that
uh you know that was kind of a um
a seminar and and like hey here's all
these places that you can go and look
and
uh yeah i'll say this as somebody who
works in in you know ancient philosophy
ado's irritation
is not just admirable it's enviable
you know to the point where you're like
man i wish i understood these people as
good as he does
you know he's read so much stuff you
know
and uh you know i mean you're a scholar
scholar
exactly yeah but he's also he writes in
a way that's very i think
very readable too yeah well i guess at
least the translations
at least for our english speakers that's
true i haven't read him in french and
i'm somebody who translates from french
so i probably shouldn't admit that but
um i don't know if the french is as good
as the english translations
so shifting topic i asked sellers a
question
and he didn't quite answer this one but
he did give
an answer to a question i didn't ask
which i think is
is quite interesting and important as
well
there's a lot of important reason
thinkers
you mentioned pierre aldo who i think
the phrase philosophy is a way of life
is particularly associated with but we
can
as you do in your work talk about others
like martha nussbaum
or michel foucault i think aleister
mcintyre is coming at this in a similar
way
that albeit is a dedicated aristotelian
who sometimes gets some of the other
figures a bit
uh you know idiosyncratically presented
we'll say
so a lot of these big names and and you
yourself
i would include in that as well they all
have a background or a grounding
in the history of philosophy an
appreciation for it ado
particularly as a scholar doing works
not necessarily to push the philosophy
as a way of life
idea but just for their own sake do you
think that's an important
part of doing something whatever we're
going to call it whether it's philosophy
is a way of life tradition constituted
rationality or
philosophy is therapy do you think it's
important that people
turn towards history or could you do
philosophy as a way of life just sort of
making it up on the fly
in the present i think one of the things
that comes through
quite clearly when looking at the
ancient material
is the place of role models and examples
and so as you know for lots of ancient
philosophers socrates becomes a kind of
emblematic figure or role model
even if you are not yet a socrates you
ought to try to live as if you were a
socrates epithet says
and for the epicureans epicurus becomes
that emblematic figure
diogenes the cynic is an emblematic
figure for lots of people
and so i think that's really
what can help to bring philosophy as a
way of life to home
for many people the idea that you've got
some kind i mean obviously all these
figures get mythologized right
so um no one's perfect but the the idea
of a kind of a
of an image of what an ideal life might
look like that people are working
towards
i think that's really valuable and i
think if you're studying the history of
philosophy you can find examples like
that
not necessarily ancient you might think
of other figures in the history of
philosophy as well
i think if you were just trying to do it
in a very abstract sort of contemporary
ethics kind of way
you'd lose that and i think that that
would mean that it'd be much difficult
to kind of bring it alive for people
so i think i think the historical
element is quite quite valuable
so what do you make of that is
it really important that we have these
role models like the stoic sage or
epicurus or whoever else it is what
i think he's right um
but what do you what do you what's your
take on that
it's the idea of a a sage
like this kind of idealized version of
of these things and
he said it and i i would like to
reiterate the
you know it's the kind of like the
the legend of these people more than the
actual people i i guess
i've met no one which i would consider
to be a perfect role model
in all cases i've found people that can
be definitely be a role model
in certain aspects um but they're never
without
you know some small caveat and
yeah um and to not you know
put someone so high on a pedestal that
when
they eventually you notice their tarnish
that you are devastated by that tarnish
that's probably some really good advice
that that actually could be one of the
practices that we talk about down the
line you know
figuring out whether your attachment to
role models
is a helpful one a realistic one or
whether it's a
what would you say like a pathological
one you know
so that's that's a good lead into
another topic that we asked about which
is uh
spiritual exercises
so another element that comes through
particularly in
ando who calls these spiritual exercises
is philosophical practices philosophy
involves doing things and not just once
but making them
a consistent practice so
how important are these and why are
these important for philosophy as a way
of life
this is a really interesting question
that i've been grappling with
for quite a while and in particular in
connection
to the modern stars is a movement that
we're both involved in
because in that lots of people talk
about practices
a lot of people you encounter who say
they're really interested in stoicism
they want to be a stoic
it's all about what do i do what are the
practices that i do
and initially when we started thinking
about that i really struggled
with that idea i really struggled to
come up with okay what would
philosophical practice be because to my
mind
the important part of the whole thing
the philosophical part of the whole
thing
are the ideas and the arguments
so it might be that you want
those ideas and arguments to impact on
how you're
how you live you want to put them into
practice
that's quite different from saying
philosophy is simply a set of practices
right and so i mean this is a a comment
that's often been made when people talk
about pierre hedoe's work
in places he seems to say philosophy is
simply
a set of spiritual exercises which
people understand as
it's simply a set of practices and some
people are pushed back against that idea
and said well surely it's not just that
surely philosophy is about offering
arguments and reasons
for whatever positions that you want to
hold i'm
a little bit wary of the idea that
philosophy is merely a set of practices
and i think you this is the a comment
that martha nussman makes in her book
therapy of desire she points it towards
michel foucault
and i think perhaps slightly unfairly um
i don't think it's necessarily a fair
criticism of foucault but i think the
point
ought to be taken very seriously which
is that if you try to reduce
philosophy merely to a set of practices
how does it differ from anything else
that you might think of as a set of
practices like a religion
or or some other kind of ancient mystery
cult or whatever it might be
you mustn't forget the arguments and the
rational claims that are being made
that's that's the philosophy
that you want to put into practice and
if we think philosophy is a way of life
merely as
a set of practices you know i'm going to
have a cold shower because it's going to
make me resilient
it's like that's not philosophical right
um i mean you might be a stoic and you
might decide to do that too
but you've got to have those stoic ideas
and arguments in in place as well it's
not just about
taking cold showers if people think that
that's what it involves
in your article that you'd mentioned uh
titled what is philosophy as a way of
life
towards the end you brought that up
twice in in considering different models
of philosophy's way of life
saying that the danger was not just of
say losing arguments or the emphasis on
on that
or rational inquiry but that there could
be a
danger of losing and i forget exactly
the phrase you had it was very nicely
put
something like the motivation of truth
and is that how does truth figure
into this yeah i think it's fundamental
if we think
if we think we're doing philosophy and
we're taking that claim
seriously that the beliefs that you hold
as a philosopher
are ones that you think are i mean the
ones you think are plausible
at the very least if not true that you
think you've got good reasons to hold
right that seems to be really important
what we don't want to do is reduce
philosophy to merely some kind of
therapy
or self-help whereby people say
to themselves i'm going to believe these
sorts of things because they're going to
make me feel nice
right that's not philosophy right you're
going to have to have some
conviction that the beliefs or the
values that you're holding
are right and it's because you believe
they're right or true
i however want to phrase it that you
think they're
important enough actually to go to to
let guide your life
i mean truth is a grandiose term right
but
you've got to have some conviction or
some belief that seems fundamental
to me yeah so that that covers quite a
bit
um what what do you what are your
thoughts on that
all right first thing is the kind of
like this distinction between
uh flossie is life hacks versus practice
when we're actually a praxis
when we're talking about practice and so
practice is
putting theory into practice it is a
a practice that has been buttressed with
the foundation
of theory yeah i i think
there are a lot of people out there who
think that you can take
whether it's you know stoicism or
cynicism or epicureanism or
pick whatever it is you could you could
they say just boil it down for me into
the things that i have to do
and you know i think sellers is right
you could be you might become more
resilient by taking
cold showers but you won't become
resilient
along the lines that it would it would
you know help you to become
resilient if that makes sense you know
the the theory
is there to do more than just be a a
nice set of ideas to think about it's
there to
make the like you were talking about
earlier right the why
of the practices why the hell am i doing
all this stuff
it's like i'm going to be resilient for
resiliency's sake
and what does that get you uh you can
you can now stay in the shower cold
shower great yeah well you can mark it
off on your your card
right oh yeah you've filled in all these
different blocks
i mean that's there's something to that
i mean one of the questions i
kind of wish i had asked him as well how
much of the philosophy do you
need to know that or study in order to
provide that framework and i sh you know
i kind of regret not thinking of that at
the time
because isn't that kind of the key
question although i think it goes
hand in hand you have to know enough
theory in order for the practices to
have weight but then doing the practices
then
build into the theory a lot of times at
least i've had from my practice
of stoicism and also like meditation of
like okay
these are the ideas that you hear about
in the abstract and then you actually
experience it and the experience
is uh a very
buttressing effect i think that there
there are sometimes cases where only by
doing the practice and then having an
experience
can you really fully understand what the
theory is talking about
you know so he also talked about this
idea of like truth as a motivating force
for
why you wanted to do these things or at
least why you're going to choose a
particular
philosophy of life in that you know you
are not just doing
because you think that they will make
you feel good or nice that it's not a
therapy or just you know self-help but
that you have some conviction
that these beliefs that you will hold
are correct
and that they are important enough to
guide your life
yeah so what here's a question to ask
though what if what if you've actually
got them wrong what if you get into a
philosophy as a way of life
and you you're motivated by it you know
here's here's an example and i i might
take some of our our listeners off if
they're particularly attached to this
person maybe
we were talking about this a little bit
earlier i think that you could say that
ein rand's objectivism which by the way
is split into
a bunch of different factions it's not
one simple thing and they they all think
that that they've
the other people got in ran wrong but i
think ayn rand is actually proposing
philosophy as a way of life
it just happens to be one that i don't
think most of us would actually
want to endorse and it wouldn't make us
better people in many respects to follow
it
you know so maybe there has to be
at least some stock taking at a point
where you're like
i don't know is is this i you know i
understand that i've now got a
comprehensive system that helps me
understand things but is it actually
a good system is it is it in line with
with truth in a
a very broad sense right i guess
are you bringing up the the no true
randian argument here
i don't know that tell me what that is
oh it's just the note for scotsman
no no i'm not i i think there are true
randians but i think that
being a true randian in the sense of
like being a
totally devoted follower uh you know
putting all these ideas into practice
would probably make you
in some respects a
less truthful person in terms of
practical truth
you know it would lead you away from uh
you know
what so many of the other philosophies
that we we talked about
would actually say is the good life
right
uh as well as like if you've got like a
ideal of like was it well-being
i don't know if that oh the good
living well that sort of idea or no as
as in like the
uh not like a personal well-being but
like the the well-being of all
like living things as a goal yeah i
don't think that
that the randian quite turns
into that no no it would it would in
many respects militate against that
um and make it make it not only would it
say don't do that
it would it would say why you shouldn't
do that but the whys would be in some
respect misleading wise i guess you
could say
you know at least from from where we sit
so maybe we're maybe we're wrong about
that though
it could be i'm i'm definitely not a
a deep scholar van rand and so
i can't i can't claim to be like a
scholar i teach her in classes which
which is a kind of a
a strange move but i do it because i
want my students to
get a really articulate argument for why
they should all be selfish
and you know strip away some of the you
know types of selfishness that she
rightly distinguishes as as wrongheaded
and then come out on the other end
saying no i still don't buy it
i think this is it's good to know what
you're you're not
uh not accepting of right
right uh to to throw it out out of hand
uh is not a academically you know
rigorous pursuit that is the typical
academic um response though
you know she is persona non grata in
most places in academia
one of the so this is actually a good
lead into the the last
question that i put to sellers and we
have some thoughts on this topic as well
so the last question that i have for you
is
sort of a landscape one and
i'm going to restrict you from saying
the modern stoic movement
as an answer to it what would you say
are the most other interesting movements
or schools that we can call philosophy
as a way of life in the present that is
a difficult
question well i know you have a workout
very recently
about epicureanism so and i was
interested
you know when i first saw it what's he
doing over there
so is that one of the contemporary
interpretations or schools or movements
that you would say is a viable
way of life i mean i think i think we
can all learn
from a wide variety of different
philosophical schools ancient or modern
and we can all take away interesting
ideas from them
and put them into practice in our own
lives whether that be
ancient stoics epicureans aristotelians
whether it be modern existentialism
or you know a whole range of other other
things in between
and there are all sorts of schools where
we can take ideas
in terms of current contemporary
movements that have lots of weight
behind them
obviously the stoic one stands out for
at the moment i think
and not just because we've got a
first-hand view of that
but it's not it's not obvious that there
are lots of others out there at the
moment
i mean there is there is a society of
epicurus out there
and there are some people interested in
epicureanism and as you say i have
recently written a book on that and i do
think we can learn stuff from
the epicureans just as we could learn
stuff from the stoics or from many other
people
i wasn't necessarily writing it with a
view that
there was already a large community of
epicureans out there that um
it would appeal to but i'm sure there
are there are a few
but in the article that you mentioned
earlier that i wrote i
end by reflecting on lucretius in
particular
because i think he gives a really nice
account of the relationship between a
commitment to truth on the one hand
the way things really are and the
thought that we can gain some
therapeutic or practical benefit from
attending
to the way things really are and i've
always been a fan of lucretia so i read
lucretius
very early very early on in my education
and i i kind of wanted to honour that
because i think that there's
there's lots of interesting material
there as well i mean as for other
communities
it's hard hard for me to say you might
have your finger on the pulse more than
i do
all right so that's a challenge to us do
we have our finger more on the pulse
than john sellers does i and i proposed
you know in another conversation this
idea about randianism
to him and he said i have to admit you
know we don't really have any of those
over here in england that i've met and
so i can't say
but um there's there's quite a few other
um
contenders we could say for philosophy
as a way of life i think in the present
um what would you say yeah and
and so like being on meetup and
uh seeing the groups that are there
that's a great index
yeah yeah it is and and so you see
something that i've seen the
there are randian groups here um and
i guess just thinking about it recently
is there's a
a group that the um retire early
um oh what is that that caught fire
uh financial independence retire early
which is kind of this
idea of like creating a good life by
making sure that you have
enough money in the stock market that
you can just like live off 30 grand a
year
for the rest of your life you're you're
saving yourself um but i guess the
others that i uh
so are they then saying they're sort of
like limiting their
expenses in order to do that right
that's
very much along the lines of what what
seneca is proposing right and in some of
his letters where he's saying and reduce
your expenses
you're a rich man um a rich person yeah
yeah they're all about like you know
put away like 70 of your income if you
get like as much income as you can
um and you need to have what
like i think it's like 11 times your um
yearly um expenditures in order to never
have to work again
okay i mean i guess you can say there is
a philosophy there right there's
like a valuation of work and
um whether we want to be doing that or
not i i imagine a lot of these people
don't just like sit and watch the tv all
day after they
retire no i think the main idea is that
you should decouple um work from
having to live and so you now have work
because you
enjoy it and you want to do it and
having enough money is what has your
ability to actually
live in a day-to-day basis so this is
interesting because here we could make a
distinction
between um things that you do as
means right that are coming from the
philosophy and then things that are
practices in the philosophy that in some
way embody it so
like for for that there's a let's you
know live frugally
uh so that you can live freely and
commit yourself to whatever sort of
interesting work you want to do
in the future and they're living
frugally i guess you could say that is a
practice right it's something they would
continue on doing even after they reach
that
that certain point so it wouldn't just
be a means it would be a practice and i
guess that could qualify as a philosophy
as a way of life
now others that come to mind are like
humanism or veganism yeah the veganism
one is an interesting one would you
i mean so i guess the philosophers are a
fractured community you know oh yeah i
guess
like we talked about the fractured
randians yeah
they're different i know of some that
like at least have a philosophical
background in the uh whatever can feel
harm or pain on they want to reduce that
pain
and so that's kind of like that is the
bad and whatever you can do to reduce
the bad is good in that sense
and thus that results in the practice of
not eating any
animals there's a lot of overlaps
between
veganism and vegetarianism and the
effective altruist movement which came
out of utilitarian moral philosophy
and i i think definitely can be called a
philosophy as a way of life you know
it's
particularly associated with peter
singer but there's a lot of other people
in it as well could you expand on that
really quick
yeah so the idea behind well let's talk
about utilitarianism so jeremy bentham
is the
the official founder of it but it's an
idea that's been around for a long time
and you know really simply put you
should maximize
positive outcomes and minimize negative
outcomes but what makes it
utilitarianism
is that you somehow tally these up and
sort of plan it out and you do it for
everybody who's affected and you treat
everybody
as having the same like steak in it so
you know like if you and i and a couple
other people are trying to figure out
what to put on the pizza maybe we have
to vote
you know for and if somebody like wants
you know
something uh that uh is controversial
like
anchovies or yeah or pineapple
maybe that doesn't get in there now this
is a really silly trivial example but
but i mean you can expand it to
you know um city planning you know
should we have more
public transport or should we like you
know keep expanding our highways to get
as many cars on the on the thing
should we have bike routes and things
like that i mean an effective altruist
or a utilitarian
would probably be for as much good
public transport
and as much healthy modes of
transportation as
as we could have and there's i mean it
can affect all sorts of things so animal
rights
singer is a really big proponent to that
i think actually he might have
he he came at that from a utilitarian
perspective but i think he might have
talked about animal rights before he
talked about any of the other things
that he's really well known for
um so that i mean that's that's a
movement um i think the
the most interesting example of that is
the
uh the people who've taken it to heart
to go and work on wall street and then
uh live on right as little money as you
can
in new york and give everything else
away yeah he talks about that there's a
chapter on it in his
recent book the most good that you can
do
uh about people taking these careers
where traditionally we look at them and
they're like you're a money grubber you
know and they're like yeah i'm grubbing
all the money i can so i can spread it
out throughout you know the third world
and help people
yeah the incredibly spartan life to
do the most good i really like this idea
that you had about you look at meetup
and see what the groups are and i think
you can do that with like reddit and
facebook
and you can see where people are
you know it could be an ancient
philosophy it could be something more
recent
where they're taking it and they are
living it as a way of life and i think
that those meetup groups
and um forums are an important way in
which people
you know they bounce ideas off of each
other they they learn
practices they get advice um i think
that's that's a central part of
how philosophy as a way of life today
gets gets lived out
right so maybe we should talk about
practice here
yeah so you know philosophy is a way of
life um
part of what's really distinctive to it
is having philosophical practices that
are front and center
we picked out two that we are going to
just lead you through a little bit maybe
we'll do a whole show sometime
just on philosophical practices um
i thought we did that once but we can
always do it again you're right so
actually we did
yeah there's hundreds of them but why
don't you lead us through through
one of those so uh one that's seen in
many different
uh philosophies is a nightly review of
your actions
and so this is a place for you to
kind of reminisce and think about
how you acted in that day and see if
your actions actually
comport with the ideals that you hold
do they conform to these ideals and if
they don't then water you
allows you that moment to reflect and
make a plan for how you can do better
next time and i've
definitely had this and found it very
useful
and at least early on ended up starting
to really
apologize to some of the people that are
close to my life who i felt like i was
acting poorly towards
oh that's interesting so you only you
really only realize that in a
operational way you could say by doing
this nightly review
right yeah um you take for granted
sometimes your family
uh and then really looking at it from
kind of an objective
third person view at the end of the day
interesting i
could have done a lot better yeah that's
that's a great observation
so another one that that is kind of
there's
there's some similarity to it you know
we talked earlier about these
ideals of like the sage or wise person
or perfectly realized stoic or epicurean
and one of the one of the practices that
you do see
in contemporary forms of these
is considering what the role model would
do themselves like you know when you're
trying to figure out
how should i behave but also you can
submit your actions you can
you can imagine that the sage is
watching you
so whoever it is that you think has
really got it together obviously if
you're a stoic it's cato
or i don't know epictetus or whoever
right
uh if you're an epicurean it's always
got to be epicurus
but we can substitute anybody who we
think is really well put together and
imagine ourselves
like either our reasoning process and
the excuses we're about to make
or the bad behavior that we're tempted
to justify to ourselves imagine that the
person we think
really has it together is watching us
and then we can think about what would
they what would they say to us
and and that could be quite helpful this
is something actually that comes
straight out of ado he talks about the
importance of cultivating interior
dialogue right so we
we have this person and it could be
whoever you want who you think is
particularly
on the right track um i mean in my case
it could actually be like you know some
of my relatives who were upstanding
people
not only would you be ashamed of doing
the action but they could actually
say here's what's wrong with you and
here's why you shouldn't behave this way
or if you if you arrive at the point
where you're like yeah they'd be cool
with what i'm doing
maybe that's a nice positive
reinforcement you could think of like
i don't know people who you who you
really whose opinion you really value
they don't see your actions but what if
they did see your actions that can give
you uh
a sense of um accomplishment perhaps
yeah so uh you have any um book
recommendations from this interview
we've we've talked about a lot of books
in
uh this and so i should mention
some of them and we'll put links to all
of these so you can easily find them
uh the big heavy hitter front and center
obviously is pure ado
philosophy as a way of life we've
probably mentioned that you know
20 times in this episode another one is
martha nussbaum who's down at university
of chicago still
the therapy of desire that was a really
major work
in this kind of genre then we have
aleister mcintyre somebody who by the
way i can say
in in the terms of virtue ethics is the
real deal
somebody who uh not only talks the talk
but walks the walk
still around today at 92 years old and
i i would say if you have to pick one
book for him it's after virtue which was
a a very popular book
there you know we mentioned michelle
foucault you could look out at the
history of sexuality volumes one and two
that might be helpful that's what
nusbalm is targeting and then we have
john sellers of course right and we're
going to put a link to his article what
is philosophy as a way of life
highly recommended that you read it it's
really great but he has a new book out
on epicureanism called the fourfold
remedy
epicurus and the art of happiness
and so that might be a useful text for
you to go out and get as well
there he as we said you know he's moving
from the stoic camp into the epicurean
camp
right it's uh always an interesting
wall to bounce ideas off it's like oh
look stokes and epicureans
long butted heads about what the
true good is but um it is
uh the end and so we're going to leave
you with the words of john sellers
quite apt there is a good case for the
claim
that all philosophy worthy of the name
acknowledges this aspect of philosophy
that of philosophy is a way of life
which has
been there since the beginning
[Music]
you